RUSSIA'S WARN UKRAINE ARE
GRIPPING, DISTURBING, AND WE ALL
LOOK ON HEARTBROKEN UKRAINIAN
CITIZENS ARE DESTROYED.
THEY ATTEMPT TO FLEE IN THE WAKE
OF THESE UNPROVOKED ATTACKS.
PHOTOJOURNALIST HEIDI LEVINE HAS
BEEN DOCUMENTING THE WAR IN AND
AROUND KYIV FOR "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
I WANT TO START BY SHOWING SOME
PHOTOS YOU TOOK AROUND IRPIN
WHERE PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO FLEE.
YOU SEE THE DAMAGED BRIDGE
THERE.
IF YOU JUST PAUSE AND WATCH, YOU
SEE CRUTCHES THERE, A PET
CARRIER.
IF YOU TAKE TIME TO LOOK AT THE
HUMANITY OF THE PHOTO, IT'S
REMARKABLE.
AND A SERIES THERE.
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS MORE THAN
30 YEARS.
YOU'VE BEEN IN IRAQ, SYRIA,
GAZA.
AND YET YOU SAY YOURSELF AND
WHEN YOU TALK TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WITH DECADES OF EXPERIENCE
COVERING WAR, THEY ARE SHOCKED
BY WHAT THEY ARE WITNESSING.
FEARFUL OF WHAT COMES AHEAD.
HELP EXPLAIN.
>> WELL, I MEAN, IT'S TRUE.
I HAVE NOT MET ANY JOURNALIST
WHO HAS BEEN WORKING AS LONG AS
I HAVE IN THESE -- IN CONFLICT
ZONES AND COVERING WARS.
I MEAN, EVERY TIME I BUMP INTO
SOMEBODY THAT I KNOW OR SOMEBODY
I DON'T EVEN KNOW, WE'RE JUST
SHOCKED WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
HOW COULD THIS BE HAPPENING IN
2022?
IT FEELS LIKE WE HAVEN'T LEARNED
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING FROM THE --
FROM HISTORY.
AND EVERY TIME I SEE PEOPLE
FLEEING AND PEOPLE CARRYING
THEIR ELDERLY PARENTS, THEIR
GRANDPARENTS, THEIR PETS AND I'M
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT ONE PET.
I'VE MET FAMILIES THAT ARE
CARRYING THREE DOGS, THEIR
BABIES, THEIR CATS, AND ELDERLY
WOMEN AND MEN COVERED IN SNOW
THE OTHER DAY DURING A BRIEF
SNOWSTORM.
I EVEN TRIED TO HELP A WOMAN TO
WARM HER HANDS AND HER SHIRT WAS
SHOWING AND I COULD SEE THAT SHE
WAS WEARING GERIATRIC DIAPERS.
I WOKE UP AT 3:00 IN THE MORNING
AFTER PHOTOGRAPHING THAT DAY
AND, YOU KNOW, I WAS JUST HAVING
NIGHTMARES AND I THINK I CAN'T
IMAGINE BEING ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF MY CAMERA.
I MEAN, IF PEOPLE EVER IMAGINE
THAT PHOTOJOURNALISTS OR ANYONE
DOCUMENTING THIS CONFLICT OR ANY
OTHER CONFLICTS ARE SHIELDED BY
OUR LENSES AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
UNTRUE.
WE ARE FEELING VERY EMOTIONAL
AND HELP, STOPPING, PUTTING DOWN
OUR CAMERA, HELPING PEOPLE,
CRYING WITH PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE SOMETIMES JUST
REACHING OUT AND HUGGING ME AND
IT'S REALLY NOTHING THAT I'VE
EVER EXPERIENCED BEFORE.
AND WE ARE ALL AFRAID OF WHAT
CAN HAPPEN IN THE NEAR FUTURE
HERE.
>> YOU CAN HEAR YOUR EMOTION.
THE ARC OF LIFE IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A MAGICAL JOURNEY.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE RIGHT NOW.
YOU SEE A FUNERAL IN KYIV.
A FUNERAL THAT'S TOO SOON FOR
SOMEBODY WHOSE LIFE HAS BEEN CUT
SHORT.
TOO SOON BY PUTIN'S PLAN, NOT
GOD'S PLAN.
AND THEN THE OTHER END, THIS IS
A BASEMENT MATERNITY WARD,
UNDERGROUND IN KYIV TO PROTECT
THE PREGNANT MOTHERS, TRY TO
PROTECT THEM FROM WHAT'S
HAPPENING UP ABOVE.
YOU SAY WHEN YOU PUT DOWN -- YOU
CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE LENS.
BOTH THE BEGINNING AND END OF
LIFE THERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
HELL.
>> RIGHT.
AND A LOT OF THESE WOMEN,
PREGNANT WOMEN, WERE FRIGHTENED.
I MEAN, I AM A MOTHER.
I HAVE THREE CHILDREN MYSELF.
I'VE GONE THROUGH GIVING BIRTH
THREE TIMES AND IT'S SCARY
ENOUGH ON ITS OWN SO I CANNOT
IMAGINE WHAT THE SITUATION IS
LIKE FOR THEM.
THEY DON'T -- THEY ARE IN SHOCK
THAT THIS IS HAPPENING IN THEIR
OWN COUNTRY.
THAT THEY'RE IN SHOCK THAT
THEY'RE ABOUT TO GIVE BIRTH OR
HAVE GIVEN BIRTH UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE EVEN
GOING TO BE EVEN HAVE A HOME TO
GO HOME TO WITH THEIR NEWBORN
BABY OR WHAT COUNTRY THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO FLEE TO.
YOU HAVE TO ALSO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, THE MEN ARE NOT -- BETWEEN
THE AGE OF 17 AND 65 ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO LEAVE UKRAINE.
AND SO I HAVE ALSO WITNESSED SO
MANY WOMEN OF ALL AGES WITH
THEIR FAMILIES LEAVING ON THEIR
OWN, SAYING GOOD-BYE TO THEIR
HUSBANDS FROM THE WINDOW OF
TRAIN STATION.
IT'S JUST SHOCKING.
>> WE'RE SHOWING PICTURES YOU
TOOK AT THE END OF FEBRUARY.
A RESIDENTIAL BUILDING AND A
FIRE.
THERE'S A PHOTOGRAPH HERE OF THE
KYIV ZOO.
AND IN SOME WAYS, THIS IS
INCREDIBLY HEARTWARMING.
YOU SEE ONE OF THE ZOOKEEPERS
TRYING TO COMFORT AN ASIAN
ELEPHANT WHO YOU SAY IN YOUR
REPORTING IS HAVING SHOCK ISSUES
BECAUSE OF THE DRUM BEAT OF WAR.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, EVEN DURING OUR
VISIT TO THE ZOO, WE COULD HEAR
THE SOUNDS OF SIRENS.
WE COULD HEAR EXPLOSIONS IN THE
BACKGROUND.
I KNOW THAT THE ELEPHANT IS
BEING GIVEN SEDATIVES BECAUSE
HE'S ABSOLUTELY FRIGHTENED FROM
THE NOISE, WALKING BACK AND
FORTH.
I'VE HEARD THAT EVEN ONE OF THE
KEEPERS IS SLEEPING WITH HIM AT
NIGHT TO TRY TO KEEP HIM CALM.
IT'S -- I MEAN, I EVEN SAW A
CEMETERY THAT -- WHERE THE
GRAVES WERE DESTROYED FROM A
SHELLING.
SO EVEN THE DEAD ARE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO REST IN PEACE HERE.
>> HEIDI, I WANT TO COME BACK TO
ONE MORE PHOTO OF THE
FIREFIGHTER OUTSIDE THIS
APARTMENT BUILDING.
IT'S SUCH A LONELY PHOTO AND
HORRIFIC WHEN YOU SEE THE SMOKE
IN THE BACKGROUND AND YET SO
HEROIC OF THE FIRST RESPONDERS
IN THE MIDDLE OF WAR TRYING TO
DO THEIR JOB.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEBODY LIKE THAT
AND THEN AS YOU TALK ABOUT THE
TOLL ON YOURSELF, JUST HOW DO
YOU GET THROUGH THE DAY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, TALKING ABOUT
IT, I HAVE -- I'M WORKING WITH
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
I HAVE AN INCREDIBLE TEAM HERE
THAT I'M PART OF AND MOST
GRATEFUL.
I HAVE CLOSE COLLEAGUES HERE
THAT I'VE KNOWN FOR DECADES.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
ABSOLUTE -- IT'S A NIGHTMARE
ALSO ON MY OWN FAMILY AND
THEY'RE SUPER SCARED.
IT'S A NIGHTMARE FOR ALL OF OUR
FAMILIES, BUT IT'S, MOST
IMPORTANT, IT'S A TOTAL
NIGHTMARE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE.
BUT I HAVE SEEN SUCH INCREDIBLE
RESILIENCE AND I HAVE NOT MET
ANYONE OF ANY AGE WHO ISN'T
DETERMINED TO FIGHT FOR THEIR
COUNTRY WHETHER IT'S LITERALLY
PICKING UP A GUN OR ACTUALLY
PREPARING -- HELPING TO PREPARE
FOOD FOR THE FORCES OR FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORS OR FOR -- TO HELPING A
FAMILY FIND INSULIN FOR THEIR
YOUNG CHILD.
SO I THINK, AS YOU KNOW, I'M
VERY COMMITTED TO THE STORY.
WHAT I DO IS NOT A JOB.
IT FEELS LIKE IT'S A MISSION.
AND, OF COURSE, IT TAKES A TOLL
AND TALKING ABOUT IT AND BEING
ABLE TO TRY TO MAKE IT MY
AUDIENCE UNDERSTAND AND CONNECT
TO MY PHOTOS HELPS ME GET
THROUGH THE DAY.
AND JUST YESTERDAY I DID GET A
MESSAGE FROM AN AGENCY IN FRANCE
THAT SAW THE STORY ABOUT A CHILD
WHO WAS IN NEED OF INSULIN
OFFERING THE FAMILY HELP.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SEE THESE
MESSAGES, YOU KNOW THAT YOUR
WORK IS DEFINITELY DOING
SOMETHING, AND IT'S HELPING TO
MAKE A CHANGE, EVEN IF IT'S A
SMALL CHANGE OR A LITTLE
FOOTSTEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
>> AMEN.
AMEN TO THAT.
YOU'RE DOING REMARKABLE WORK,
BOTH RECORDING THIS AS A
NEWSSTORY, BUT ALSO HISTORY AS
IT UNFOLDS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK, AND
PLEASE STAY SAFE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
>> I JUST OFFER MY CONDOLENCES
TO THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES AND -- INCLUDING THE
FAMILIES OF THE JOURNALISTS WHO
HAVE BEEN KILLED IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO YOU AND TO
THE PEOPLE HERE AND EVERYONE ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE CONFLICT